21e place sur 41 tour arrive au 6e rang
parmi les onze grandes villes de 20000 à
40000 étudiants elle est comparable à
ses voisines angers et poitiers mais se
retrouve loin derrière selon la plupart
des critères 26e en termes de vie
étudiante là où la capitale du poitou se
classe 4e et la cité angevine 6e 30e
même pour le cadre de vie lorsque
poitiers s'octroie une magnifique
deuxième place parmi les quarante et une
ville étudiante française c'est l'emploi
qui permet à tour d'arriver en milieu de
tableau dans le classement final puisque
en la matière à la rive 15e mais la
ville a des atouts de taille elle est
propice pour réussir ses études à la fac
avec le 12e meilleur taux de réussite en
licence
elle a aussi d'autres points forts le
logement qui la place ex-aequo avec
saint-etienne les sports où elle partage
la 14e place avec perpignan et rouen ou
encore la culture
mais selon les critères de l'étudiant la
ville doit faire des efforts en termes
de sortie c'est à dire le nom de bar de
resto de boîtes de nuit ou encore de
parcs de loisirs et de billard une 37e
place qui surprend les principaux
intéressés
je suis pas sur quels critères qui sont
basés pour établir un classement mais et
toi étudiante à versailles avant je peux
vous dire que tu es vachement mieux
c'est ton tour j'aurais parié que ça a
était avant parce que tour quand même il
ya plein de choses à faire c'est de très
très attractifs tout ce que ça m'étonne
un peu mais la bête noire de tours ce
sont les transports avec une 41e et
dernière place du classement
il faut dire que le pass étudiants fil
bleu est à 27 euros 60 par mois
bien plus que la moyenne des autres
villes les transports c'est une
responsabilité de la communauté
d'agglomération du sitcat donc nous
allons regarder avec nos partenaires de
la communauté d'agglomération pour avoir
une politique tarifaire qui soient mieux
adaptés à la population étudiante
nous allons regarder ce qui se pratique
ailleurs et puis nous avons un comité de
pilotage ville université nous allons
mettre ce sujet à l'ordre du jour et on
va réfléchir ensemble
malgré ces quelques ombres au tableau la
ville reste attractive puisque la
population étudiante a augmenté de 6 5 %
en dix ans mais comme elle a perdu deux
places au classement général en deux ans
il faudra redoubler d'efforts pour que
sept ans
en se confirme à l'avenir